[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt heute gilt ein absolutes basic
grundrezept es gibt french toast oder
auch amerika genannt warum heißen die
arme ritter denn es ist wirklich so ein
arme-leute-essen man brauche im prinzip
nur altes toastbrot oder altes brot bzw
wenn man eben alles brot hat kann man
das super aufpimpen ein paar eier ein
bisschen milch und macht sich richtig
lecker french toast drauf draus das
ganze kann man entweder sie setzen so
wie ich es gerne esse oder eben auch
herzhaft also man muss nicht zwingend
french toast oder amerika süß verspeisen
ich zeige euch jetzt erstmal die
klassische variante und dann noch die
vegane variante
die ist nämlich auch super einfach für
die klassische variante nämlich bei 140
gramm milch etwas vanille extrakt und
eine prise zimt sechs scheiben toastbrot
ich habe jetzt hier vollkorntoast zum
ausbacken etwas butter und ich soll wir
es hier gleich mit himbeeren
erdnussbutter und kaunitz als wir
unschwer erkennen könnt mache ich jetzt
natürlich die süße variante wenn ihr es
herzhaft macht würde ich einfach sagen
wann den extrakt und zimt weglassen eine
prise salz vielleicht dazu oder einfach
neutral lassen so kann man nicht früh
stücks tisch entscheidend ob süß oder
herzhaft
so also im prinzip kann es gar kein
rezept dann ist es wirklich ganz schnell
gemacht jetzt bike welche die eier mit
der milch also zeigt hier rhein-main
wandel extrakt neigt sich dem ende zu
aber es reicht noch für die zwei sachen
dafür die rechts noch und ich zeige euch
gleich wie ihr hier alle reste noch raus
bekommt käme so während das jetzt runter
drauf habe ich schon mal dazu basta von
übrigens ja kommen eine prise hier sagt
sack
drei tage später
vier tage später
vier jahren nicht später das ganze jetzt
kurz verrühren
ich hab hunger deswegen war es jetzt
einfach ganzen welt
wir hatten vorher nicht nur so einen
erdbeer shake so resteverwertung an
früchten so und normalerweise sagt man
jetzt von beiden seiten eintauchen usw
ich mag es meist einfach ganz
pragmatisch ganz easy ich über dieses
hier und da habt ihr das gleiche in
weniger zeit
ich möchte zwar wille extrakt auch
überall dran haben diese vanille
körnchen anzuschauen und so ein bisschen
drin wenn und daher ist auch so ein
bisschen altes brot ganz gut weil es
wirklich dann die flüssigkeit perfekt
aufsaugt und wenn ihr merkt hater passt
noch ein bisschen brot dazu legt einfach
rein
das heißt verbraucht ruhig die komplette
flüssigkeit schade wäre wirklich wenn
was übrig bleibt so kommt halt echt so
wissel auch auf die feuchtigkeit des
brotes an hier noch und dann las ich
dass es hier einfach kurz ziehen und
kann schon mal die butter schmelzen
ich nehme jetzt hier einfach meinen
eckigen gusseisen britta weil ich glaube
ich alle sechs mit rein kriege ihr könnt
aber auch einfach eine teflon
beschichtete pfanne nehmen als einfach
eine anti haft fahne der anti haft fall
ist so da könnt ihr möglich mit weniger
futter auskommen arbeit muss dazu sagen
in butter gibt den armen rittern und dem
french toast einfach den perfekten
geschmack
hier habe ich ja keine beschichtung das
heißt hier brauche ich bisher mehr fett
aber bin gleichzeitig fährt jetzt ist
wichtig beim mittel hoher hitze anbraten
da jetzt einfach nicht verbrennt von
außen denn es soll ja auch ihnen gut
durch packen also wirklich nur
mittelhoch ich mach das jetzt hier so
bp gesagt die butter rein und weil ich
weiß ich habe hier keine beschichtung
ist eine brutal
ich mag butter ich dachte immer als kind
das sich grüppchen haben weil das
fleisch nicht ausgereicht hat und
gesicht
wenn dann alles ich kontrolle der hitze
jetzt hier einfach mit dem perfekt frei
sensor das heißt ich habe ihn jetzt auf
stufe 1 das heißt für mich der bretter
jetzt ist es warm der bräter behält
einfach die ganze zeit die hitze und ich
muss nicht schauen
wenn ihr das nicht habt gar nicht
schlimm ich sagen immer dazu weil viele
jetzt auch mittlerweile die geräte haben
und einfach immer wieder fragen wann
benutzt du denn sensor waren dem zuwachs
sensor also ich benutze ich setz wie
gesagt stufe eins oder ansonsten ganz
einfach bei niedriger temperatur jetzt
lege ich dir ein und wachse dann für
etwa zwei bis drei minuten von jeder
seite aus bis sie schenkt goldbraun sind
[Musik]
und den rest dem teller einfach so
nochmal drüber verteilen ganz
gleichmäßig gerade so auf denen die oben
lagen die unten diese nämlich richtig
schön nass perfekt und ich freue mich
das schon richtig drauf endlich
auspacken und gleich serviert
[Musik]
und ich habe jetzt hier einfach perfekt
frei stufe vier gewählt so kann ich die
french toast die arme ritter wirklich
perfekt goldbraun ausbacken und die
temperatur bleibt immer schon gleich ihr
müsst einfach mal gucken eine tasse
durch heran je nachdem was für
kochgeschirr auch habt erstmal lieber
niedriger starten stufe eins zwei drei
und wenn ihr merkt okay es kann noch
brauner werden dann im dreifach stufe 4
[Musik]
ja und jetzt im prinzip am besten direkt
auf den teller und servieren
ich werde jetzt aber gleich noch die
veganer machen aber ich zeige euch nicht
diese hier servieren
daher nehme ich jetzt kurz raus und
damit sie jetzt einfach nicht
übereinander gestapelt nass werden und
die knusprigkeit verlieren sagt sich die
codes ihren uns läuft hier so das wasser
im mund zusammen ja ich bei dir auch
kamera noch ok na ja schallte es noch
hier kurz aus
lecker achtung jetzt mal so ich könnte
natürlich sagen wie ihr möchtet
aber ich zeige euch jetzt mal meine
vorschlag ich glaube ich darf ich gar
nicht sagen wie viele davon nicht essen
kann
ja ich glaub ich machen hörenberg sogar
ich muss jetzt gratis foto andreas ich
muss gerade zu ihrem foto denken denkt
wie ein fotograf
ja
ich bin halt team erdnussbutter und
rückenschmerzen spielstart team
erdnussbutter zimt zucker ging also
eigentlich zimt zucker drauf und ihr
seid perfekt bedient bin ich auch bin
ich auch fällen als ich bin eigentlich
fern von allem alles mit ja alles und
jetzt noch so cacau nebst accounts ist
er praktisch die natürlichste form der
schokolade denn es ist einfach
gebrochene kakaobohne ob das gefällt mir
schon ganz gut und jetzt wissen süßen
schnee das ist praktisch der puderzucker
denn nicht schmilzt french toast
[Musik]
ich sehe schon wir kommen nicht zur
veganen variante bevor wenn ich probiert
haben also ja ich muss jetzt nicht
probieren lassen okay das ist auch schön
aus ich habe die apples mutter einfach
ein bisschen erwärmt so fließt zittern
ich finde man muss jetzt schon viele
himbeeren dazu essen denn dass der
french toast ist er praktisch nicht süß
da ist ja so recht neutral die kakao nix
von kranj tiefer schnee wirklich schneit
es dir kurz und ich geb dir unserem
stück ist schon eine sitzung pizza rat
an die sally das ist für deinen einsatz
[Musik]
ja ja schon da setzt ja noch aus und
dann gibt es versionen 2
[Musik]
es ist so die einfachsten sachen machen
sich einfach so glücklich wir sind
gerade wie auf wolke sieben jetzt zeige
ich euch die vegane version dann nämlich
praktisch nur pflanzen milch dafür und
bananen als ersatz also hab ich jetzt
hier 200 gramm vegane pflanzen milch
zwei bananen da brauche ich 250 gramm
butter vanille extrakt und zimt die
sechs scheiben etwas vegane butter zum
ausbacken und dieser wäre ich jetzt mit
blaubeeren physalis diesem schnee und
schokoladencreme ich muss jetzt gestehen
die schokoladencreme ist es nicht vegan
das ist in der not geben aber da konnte
ich dem nicht widerstehen wir haben auch
veganer schokoladencreme darf bzw ich
machte sogar selber gerne selbst
gemachten schmuck creme
aber da ist kein veganer probiert ich
meine wenn er wegen seit dem tier
einfach vegane schokocreme wir nehmen
jetzt die so ist es halt so bestimmt
aber unseres teams sara ist ein
franchise die genau was ich jetzt machen
wäre ich es ganz kurz die banane ab die
bananen dürfen auch wirklich schon mega
drive sein und jetzt hier 250 gramm
du kannst du hier dann macht alle so
hunger hunger macht schnell reifer die
banane umso süsser natürlich ich brauche
sogar noch ein bisschen habe ich nicht
egal wo egal
ich habe jetzt keine bananen basica
genau jetzt noch den trick mit dem waren
in der extrakt da bleibt ja immer gern
so ein rest übrig ist natürlich vor der
wahl machen müssen egal ich gebe hier
einfach mit rein
ich gebe so manchmal mache ich das auch
für den morgendlichen kaffee wenig
saison wandel extrakt ist er spüre ich
kurz mit der milch aus geht es im café
er ein und guckt dann löst sich nämlich
schön alles und ihr habt wirklich jedes
kleine fitzelchen an wandel extrakt
verwertet das kommt hier dazu das ist
viel schwarz wie könnte es auch mit rum
zum beispiel machen dann könnte das
sogar in der flasche lassen sollte es
dann noch nicht vertauschen mit eurem
anderen wandel extrakt was nämlich nicht
alkoholisch iss sind drei
jetzt kurz pürieren ihr könnt natürlich
auch die bananen einfach mit der gabel
zerdrücken aber so werden sie einfach
etwas feiner
[Musik]
ich muss sagen 200 gramm bananen hat
jetzt auch super ausgereicht hier mache
ich jetzt aber solche übergießt sie
tatsächlich erst mal einzeln denn diese
milch ist einfach etwas dickflüssiger
gottes zwischen lecker aus
in der zwischenzeit könnt ihr schon mal
die butter wieder schmelzen und euren
gusseisen bräter oder eben auch eure
pfanne einfach erhitzen und jetzt wieder
einfach auspacken
ich glaube tatsächlich da kann nicht
mehrere draus machen denn die
flüssigkeit ist vielmehr recht mehr als
nur für sechs fraktionen
[Musik]
anrichten also was ich sagen muss zum
einen ich hab natürlich jetzt mehr autos
raus bekommen und zum anderen brauchen
sie etwas länger im ausparken den
eisstock natürlich schneller als jetzt
hier die milch mit der banane praktisch
verdampft und durch backt aber trotzdem
die oberfläche schön knusprig ich höre
das jetzt wieder so ich glaube ich mache
tatsächlich 5 gegolten das noch drauf
und hier habe ich jetzt die schokocreme
erwärmt ich kann mir schon die
kombination schoko banane vorstellen du
auch zurücknehmen so bananenscheiben
wenn jetzt auch gut aber die werden
schnell braun
das muss man wissen und diese zahl ist
wie gut passt die hier bitte sagt so
bitteschön
vega das bekommt sarah zu fotografieren
in georgia wir richten uns schnell
unsere teller an während die anderen
noch auspacken
ich bin eh pärchen tellern also ich muss
sagen da die fotos also den teller
angerichtet für die fotos sieht hammer
mässig aus wenn wir jetzt am
frühstückstisch sitzen oder mittagstisch
oder abend ist egal war noch immer dann
gibt es natürlich die french toast auf
einem teller jeder nimmt sich ein runter
belegt ihn weil man will ja auch so viel
belag wie möglich auf dem einen haben
ich glaube ich bin der einzige mensch
der das mit dem pizza rat macht vegan
veganer french toast
oh mein gott ich glaube ich bin
tatsächlich die banane french toast
variante 100 millionen mal besser als
die variante richtige
geschmacksexplosion geschmacksexplosion
oh mein gott
probiert auf jeden fall beide varianten
aus schreibt mir was euch am besten
schmeckt also ich würd sagen wir stimmen
ab zwischen french toast mit dem zucker
french toast fruchtig grenzach egal
stimmt einfach in die kommentare
weil vielleicht habt ihr noch bessere
vorschläge andere vorschläge herz auf
die vorschläge
und wir können mal french toast deluxe
machen wenn ihr möchtet schreibt gerne
in die kommentare
und dann sehen wir wieder um uns wieder
beim nächsten mal die rezepte gibt's
natürlich auch sex - blog.de in meiner
kostenlosen app wo er sie hoch und
runter rechnen könnt je nachdem wie groß
die pokern bei euch sein soll
also wird bald
[Musik]